let's take a few more calls via the
david pakman show discord you can find
it at davidpakman.com
discord slash discord is the place let's
go to harper from europe europe is such
a vague location harper
oh yeah i'm actually in france right now
sorry all right love france yeah
yeah um i've been here for about a month
anyway uh regarding the kyle written
australia no i'm kidding um
i just wanted to say since i've been
here for over a month and you're in
spain in august i wanted to touch on the
whole anti-vaccine sure anti-vaxx
scene yes um
yeah
um so i've heard very often about
american politics that were sort of like
kind of a crap show and
people look from other countries in on
the united states and like what the heck
is going on
but i wanted to say there's sort of an
exception to be made and not sure if you
agree
with the anti-vaxx situation
uh here while i'm in france it seems
like since i left the united states i'm
from california
uh things are just as bad over here
and yes it's one of those issues we've
talked about it in france i don't want
to cut you off but just so much to
remind my audience
i have mentioned in france they are
having a serious anti-vaxx issue italy
as well by the way but in france i think
the government did something astute
which is instead of doing a straight
correct me if i'm wrong instead of doing
a straight up vax requirement they've
just said if you want to go here here
there there there you need proof of
vaccination you don't have to go and get
a vaccine but if you want to hang out in
these cafes or movie theaters or
whatever the case may be and it is it is
made as i understand it a lot more
people sort of say
well i really want to do that so i'm
going to go and get a vaccine
yeah that that's that's absolutely true
um and then there's a small aspect of
this that i don't quite see in the
united states that i would argue makes
it slightly worse over here okay and
that is that um
the if you split the the groups people
who are vaccinating people who are not
there's more animosity over here between
those two groups than there is in the
united states really it seems a bit more
tame where i came from yeah yeah uh and
then i was in catalonia and it seemed
about the same over there and i was
wondering since you were
in spain
which uh has part of catalonia about
half or maybe two-thirds
was spain like in in sort of the realm
of of of countries that have an
anti-vaxx uh situation or was it like
not at all no in fact part of the united
states at the time that i was in spain
spain was only about 45 vaccinated but
when european countries were polled do
you want the vaccine
spain was off the charts it was
something like 88 or 91 of spaniards
were saying i plan to get vaccinated
which was one of the highest in all of
europe
ah interesting yeah arthen thank you all
right thank you appreciate that great uh
great call from france there
france
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119 but nebia
is giving you ten percent off when you
go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video